in the previous video you saw the basic
blocks of implementing a deep neural
network a for propagation step for each
layer and a corresponding backward
propagation step let's see how you can
actually implement these steps will
start to for propagation recall that
what this will do is input a L minus 1
and output a L and the cash ZL and we
just said that from implementational
point of view maybe we'll cache WL + BL
as well just to make the functions call
a bit easier in the programming exercise
and so the equations for this should
already look familiar the way to
implement a fourth function is just this
equals WL x a l minus 1 plus B L and
then a l equals the activation function
applied to Z and if you want a vector
rise implementation then it's just that
times a L minus 1 plus B with the be
adding beeping uh python for costing and
a l equals he applied element wise to z
and remember on the diagram for the
forth step right we had this chain of
bosses going forward so you initialize
that with feeding and a 0 which is equal
to X so you know you initialize this
really what is the input to the first
one right it's really um a zero which is
the input features to either for one
training example if you're doing one
example at a time or a capital zero the
entire training set if you are
processing the entire training set so
that's the input to the first fort
function in the chain and then just
repeating this allows you to compute
forward propagation from left to right
next let's talk about the backward
propagation step here your goes to input
D al and output D al minus 1 and D wo
and DB let me just write out the steps
you need to compute these things
DZ l is equal to da l alamin Weis
product with G of L prime Z of L and
then computed derivatives
DW l equals d ZL times AF l minus 1 i
didn't explicitly put that in the cache
but it turns out you need this as well
and then DB l is equal to DZ l and
finally da of L minus 1 there's equal to
WL transpose times DZ l ok and I don't
want to go through the detailed
derivation for this but it turns out
that if you take this definition the da
and plug it in here then you get the
same formula as we had in there
previously for how you compute DZ l as a
function of the previous DZ ow in fact
well if I just plug that in here you end
up that DZ L is equal to WL plus 1
transpose DZ l plus 1 times G L prime z
FL I know this is a looks like a lot of
algebra but actually double check for
yourself that this is the equation we
had written down for back propagation
last week when we were doing in your
network with just a single hidden layer
and as reminder this times this
element-wise product but so all you need
is those four equations to implement
your backward function and then finally
I'll just write out the vectorized
version so the first line becomes DZ l
equals d a o element-wise product with
GL prime of z oh maybe no surprise there
DW l becomes 1 over m DZ l times
a o minus 1 transpose and then DB l
becomes 1 over m and Peter Som DZ L then
access equals 1
keep dims equals true we talked about
the use of an Peter Som in the previous
week to compute DB and the finally da L
minus 1 is WL transpose times D Z of L
so this allows you to input this
quantity da over here and output DW l DP
l the derivatives you need as well as da
L minus 1 right as follows so that's how
you implement the backward function so
just to summarize um take the input X
you might have the first layer maybe has
a rather activation function then go to
the second layer maybe uses another
value activation function goes to the
third layer maybe has a sigmoid
activation function if you're doing
binary classification and this outputs y
hat and then using Y hat you can compute
the loss and this allows you to start
your backward iteration I draw the
arrows for us I guess I don't have to
change pens too much where you were then
have back prop compute the derivatives
compute you know DW 3 DB 3 DW 2 DP 2 DW
1 DB 1 and along the way you would be
computing I guess the cash would
transfer Z 1 Z 2 Z 3
and here you pass backward da - and da
one this could compute da zero but we
won't use that so you can just discard
that right and so this is how you
implement for a prop and back prop for a
three-layer your network now there's
just one last detail that I didn't talk
about which is for the forward recursion
we would initialize it with the input
data X how about the backward recursion
well it turns out that D a of L when
you're using logistic regression when
you're doing binary classification is
equal to Y over a plus 1 minus y over 1
minus a so turns out that the derivative
of the loss function with respect to the
output we're expected Y hat can be shown
to be equal to dis if you're familiar
with calculus if you look up the loss
function L and take derivatives respect
to Y hat and respect to a you can show
that you get that formula so this is the
formula that you should use for da for
the final layer capital L and of course
if you were to have a vectorized
implementation then you initialize the
backward recursion not with this there
will be a capital A for the layer L
which is going to be you know the same
thing for the different examples right
over a for the first training example
plus 1 minus y for the first training
example over 1 minus a for the first
training example both on top down to the
M training example
so 1 minus a of them so that's how you
to implement the vectorized version
that's how you initialize the vectorized
version of backpropagation so you've now
seen the basic building blocks of both
for propagation as well as back
propagation now if you implement these
equations you will get a correct
implementation for prop and back prop to
get you the derivatives you need you
might be thinking wow those are all
equations I'm slightly confused I'm not
quite sure I see how this works and if
you're feeling that way my advice is
when you get to this week's programming
you will be able to implement these for
yourself and there'll be much more
concrete and I know there was a lot of
equations and maybe some of equations
didn't make complete sense but if you
work through the calculus and the linear
algebra which is not easy so you know
feel free to try but that's actually a
bundle more difficult derivations in
machine learning it turns out the
equations roll down at just the calculus
equations for computing the derivatives
especially in background but once again
if this feels a little bit abstract a
little bit mysterious to you my advice
is when you've done their prime exercise
it will feel a bit more concrete to you
although I have to say you know even
today when I implement a learning
algorithm sometimes even I'm surprised
when my learning algorithm
implementation works and it's because
lot of the complexity of machine
learning comes from the j-turn rather
than from the lines of code so sometimes
you feel like you implement a few lines
of code not question what it did but
there's almost magically works and
because of all the magic is actually not
in the piece of code you write which is
often you know not too long it's not
it's not exactly simple but there's not
you know ten thousand a hundred thousand
lines of code but you feed it so much
data that sometimes even don't work the
machine learning for a long time
sometimes it's so you know surprises me
a bit when my learning algorithm works
because a lot of the complexity of your
learning algorithm comes from the data
rather than necessarily from your
writing you know thousands and thousands
of lines of code all right so that's um
how you implement deep neural networks
in the game this will become more
concrete when you've done their primary
exercise before moving on I want to
discuss in the next video want to
discuss hyper parameters and parameters
it turns out that when you're training
deep nets being able to organize your
hyper parameters as well will help you
be more efficient in developing your
networks in the next video let's talk
about exactly what that means